got a statement here from our clients so
we're gonna play that on the loudspeaker
30 years I've been kind of the the
supplier of video of the environmental
movement that's what I did I would go
along take the pictures and give them
away which is why people have seen my
footage for years in all kinds of films
I did it for free I continued to do so
Whale Wars all these other people are
jumping in because they think it's great
TV after they're gone I'll still be
there doing the same thing because it's
unfortunately as we shut down one
illegal operation they pop up elsewhere
so that doesn't ever seem to be an end
you go to the feral islands where the
ferry
takes place every year the camera is the
most you know is is the greatest weapon
in the world without the camera no one
and no two guys stood in front of an ice
breaker there would be no environmental
movement without a camera no one knows
that someone stood up in front of a
harpoon and maybe whales were worth
saving maybe it was worth risking one's
life to make these issues known as I say
in my film perception in our world fire
outranked reality because we weren't big
enough to stop anything sinking one
driftnet power block meant nothing with
1,800 ships but ramming one ship it was
a shot that was heard around the world
and people took notice and actually
drift nets were banned
well we're called environmental
terrorists are we the terrorists I mean
my film answers that question you just
have to watch it and figure out okay are
they the terrorists well gee I don't
think so
and it's not for me to decide who the
terrorists history tells that story and
if there are historians writing history
in 500 years time then for certain we
won't be the terrorists will be the
heroes if there is no history written
then we'll have lost and hopefully
that's not the case I want people to
come out of my film being happy and not
saying okay these guys did it they even
seemed to have fun doing it maybe it's
worth taking on the challenge it isn't
all gloom and doom it isn't over you
know we're young we have a future we
have to do something about it we have to
think differently we have to you know
become one more with our environment we
can't keep eating it up it's all God